[MUSIC PLAYING]
DREW PHILP: Thank you all
so much for being here.
I very much appreciate it.
So my name is Drew Philp.
I went to school
here at U of M. I
come from a pretty
blue collar family.
And I felt really lucky to
get the education that I did.
So when school was over--
this was in 2008--
I saw so many people
leaving the state
that I wanted to stay here.
And I thought that I got
this world-class education,
and I wanted to use it at home
for something good, however
naive that that may
have been at the time.
So I moved to Detroit
because I thought
that was where I could
have the biggest impact.
So what I were to do in
Detroit would affect my cousin
in Kalamazoo, framing
out houses for my sister
in Lansing, who's a nurse.
And when I was there,
this was the market crash.
And I decided to buy a house
because I wanted to keep myself
there, because so many
people had told me,
what are you doing here?
You're throwing your
life away being here.
And everyone leaves.
Sometimes people come, and
this is the place of leaving.
It is the city of leaving.
Over the last decade,
I believe, one
in four elementary school-aged
children has left the city.
Obviously, the
city has been built
for almost three
times the amount
of people that live there now.
So buying a house was a
way to keep myself there.
If I had a house, I
couldn't just leave.
At the time, there was
no way to rent it out.
So in 2009, I purchased an
abandoned house for $500.
It was filled with trash.
10,000 pounds of trash I took
out of just the first floor.
I took out the better
part of a Dodge Caravan,
cut into pieces with
a reciprocating saw
in my house, needles, human
shit, all kinds of stuff.
The house had no windows,
no plumbing, no electricity,
and had a pornographic
hole in the roof.
So I fixed that up
with my own hands.
And I live there now.
So over almost the last decade--
I purchased the house in 2009.
And I wrote about the
experience in this book.
The house is just the
spine for the book, a way
to get people through the
narrative to really talk
about some of the
social issues that
are going on in Detroit and,
to a larger extent, the United
States.
SPEAKER: If you haven't
read the book yet,
I hope you all get a chance
to, because he touches
on a myriad of issues,
ranging from policing
to consumerism to all of
those topics in Detroit.
But also, I think
your quote is, Detroit
is America, just with the
volume turned all the way up.
So you have these
very American stories,
but it's amplified because
it's happening in Detroit.
And one of the things
you do in the book
is, you make a very conscious
choice about how you're
going to build the house.
And you want to
build it yourself.
You want to use materials that
are sourced a certain way.
I guess, what did that decision
process look like in terms of,
what drove you to make those
decisions on what you put
into the house,
and how long did it
take you to accumulate
all those things when
you were building it?
DREW PHILP: So that
decision came out
of just general
stubbornness a lot.
I wanted to work for all the
money that went into the house.
I didn't feel like
I wanted to take out
a mortgage, for example, and pay
someone already rich interest
to be able to do that.
I wanted to own it outright.
And I wanted to have
nobody tell me what to do.
A huge part of my
life is, I just
don't want anyone
to tell me what
to do so I can make ethical
decisions for myself.
So I didn't take out any loans.
I didn't take any kind
of foundation money.
If I would have
called the house art,
the foundations would have
been throwing money at it,
and it would have been easier,
in some ways, to do so.
But I wanted to be free,
in a certain sense.
And I think, often, free
money can be golden handcuffs.
And I wanted to just
do that on my own.
Nobody can take it away.
I suppose the city
can if I don't
pay my taxes or something.
I also wanted to change
myself by building a house
and become the kind of person
that I wanted to become.
And changing-- excuse
me, building the house
did change me.
I lived without heat for two
years in Detroit winters,
which were almost two years,
which was a huge, huge deal.
I found something inside of
myself that was very real.
It was a hard time.
I'm not going to lie,
it was difficult.
But I found some
things that I didn't
know I had, or were
buried so deeply that I
wasn't able to access them.
SPEAKER: Can you
talk a little bit
about the community in Detroit
that helped you through this?
Because that's a big focus
of the book when you first
moved to Detroit.
Then as you're
building the house,
your neighbors, being a
white guy in a city that,
traditionally, it's
still 80% black today,
which is the reverse
of the suburbs--
the suburbs in
metro are 80% white.
And so just the
community you came into,
the people that you encountered,
things on those lines.
DREW PHILP: But Detroit is the
most racially segregated metro
area in the United
States by far.
And I'm a young white guy with
an education moving in there.
Obviously, I have a
lot more privilege
than a whole lot of people
that live in Detroit, not just
my skin color, but education,
background, things like that.
And there is a persistent
myth in Detroit
that Detroit is this
kind of blank slate
where, because the
city is half empty,
they forget about
the other half.
So people always--
often, excuse me--
want to come in and
start changing things.
I'd like to try it how it was.
And that was, honestly, how I
thought when I was moving in,
that I'm going to save Detroit.
I'm going to save the city.
This is the city that's
loomed over my childhood.
And I'm going to use my
well-read, 21-year-old white
kid education to save that.
And what I found was
something very different,
that America, American popular
culture and capitalism,
to a large extent, left Detroit.
And in that vacuum, people
created a very distinct
culture.
I call it radical
neighborliness in the city
where people look
out for one another.
People say hello to one another.
It's like the opposite
of New York City where
you wander around and people
won't look you in the eye
and nobody wants
to say hi, where
people have done some pretty
stunning things, for me,
to help me along.
I was lucky enough to find
a number of different kind
of flavors, I call
them, of people
that wanted to just be left
alone and do their own thing
and raise their children
and live their lives how
they wanted to.
In the book, I call one of
these places Forestdale,
which was started by one of
the finest men I've ever met.
His name is Paul Weertz.
He was a teacher at
the Catherine Ferguson
Academy, which was a school for
pregnant and parenting mothers.
His idea 20, 30 years
ago was to teach
the young women to raise
their children by first
raising plants and animals.
So there was a working farm
on the grounds of the school
that was enormous.
I forget how many acres it
was, but it was stunning.
They had horses and
cows, dozens of beehives
and fruit trees,
all kinds of stuff.
And he also started this block,
although it wasn't intentional,
with other like-minded
folks where
they would bale hay for the
horses and chickens and cows
at the school.
You can walk baseball
stadium from here.
And baling hay in Detroit's
wild to think about.
But it's also pretty smart, too.
So one of the folks that I
respect and liked quite a bit
was Grace Lee Boggs, who
I called Detroit's patron
saint of change.
She was a philosopher
in the old school sense.
Excuse me.
And there is now a Boggs School.
She has recently passed away.
What I found was a very strong,
interesting community in a way
that I don't think
exists anywhere else
in the United States.
And the city wasn't blank.
And I guess the way I
put in the book was,
I wanted to add my
voice to the chorus,
rather than overwrite
that or be the soloist.
SPEAKER: I'm curious how you
think Detroit has changed now
since you wrote the book.
And you've mentioned
these things
during the course of
the book, the changes
that you see in the city.
But there is development
downtown now.
There's development in
some of the neighborhoods.
Some of it is publicly funded.
Some of it's privately funded.
How do you look at
development now?
And how have things changed
in your neighborhood
and in Detroit since
you wrote the book?
And is it for
better or for worse?
DREW PHILP: As we
talked about earlier,
I think it's a mixed bag.
So we are losing some things
with this development.
And obviously, we're
gaining the obvious ones--
jobs, economics, and such.
I think that development
has been rather uneven
in terms of race.
I think most of
that development is
going to a very few
neighborhoods, specifically
midtown and downtown.
And that money isn't making its
way out to the neighborhoods
where I live and where you live.
I call it trickle-down
urbanism, because the idea
is that if we fix
the city center,
then that will trickle down.
If it works like
trickle-down economics,
I don't think
that's a great idea.
I think the poster
child for this is,
just a week after Detroit
declared bankruptcy--
it was the largest municipal
bankruptcy in United States
history--
we gave more than $350
million to Mike Ilitch,
who is a billionaire, to
build the new hockey stadium.
So there was no money, but
we could find $350 million
to give this already
very wealthy person money
to build a hockey stadium.
The question I
ask is, what would
happen if we gave out 700
half-million-dollar small
business grants and loans?
That would make the city
look be very, very different
with 700 new small
businesses in the city.
I think that we're
repeating some
of the mistakes of the past.
I don't think race gets talked
about enough, especially
in the most racially
segregated metro area in the US
where, literally, Detroit
is more than 80% black
and the suburbs are the reverse.
So I think that it's hopeful
to see what's going on.
And I like it.
I think that we need to be
very careful about democracy,
though, as well.
People like Dan Gilbert
and some of the foundations
who are generally
doing good things,
there's no way to
vote these people out
if we don't like
what they're doing.
And so that presents a
large problem for democracy.
I mean, everything's going well
right now, but if that changes,
what is our recourse?
SPEAKER: I'm curious, too,
more specifically as you've
seen things in the
neighborhood change,
so does anybody
here know the name
Hantz Bank, Hantz Farms at all?
So to give you a little bit of
background-- and you mention
this person in the
book a little bit--
so very shortly after
the recession in Detroit,
there was a bank that
came in and had proposals
around buying big plots of land
on the city's east side, which
was Hantz Bank, and now
has an organization called
Hantz Farms.
And they pop up throughout
the book a little bit.
But have you seen
organizations like Hantz,
which are privately-funded
organizations,
interested in buying
land in neighborhoods?
Have you seen that
change your neighborhood
for better or for worse?
And how do you see
that playing out?
DREW PHILP:
According to NPR, 20%
of the abandoned
properties in Detroit
are owned by
foreigners, basically.
So I live next to
an abandoned house,
right next to an abandoned
house, which I can almost
touch from my bedroom window.
It's now owned by Land Bank.
But for the first
seven years I lived
there, it was owned by a
limited liability corporation.
And I could not find
who was behind--
because of how the
laws are structured,
I couldn't find out
who actually owns that.
I couldn't get to a
person on the end of that.
That house is being
kept as an investment.
I would have preferred to fix
that up and put my cousin in it
or rent it out or house
a family of refugees,
which is the current idea.
But I couldn't,
because somebody was
trying to make money from that.
If that house burns down, my
house is going to go with it,
and it's probably
going to kill my dog.
So I think we're seeing
a lot of speculation that
may be good for an
individual's pocketbook,
but it's not necessarily
good for the neighborhood.
I think that's one of the
flip sides of development.
And it's attracting
a lot of attention.
And people are saying, I
can make money from that.
In terms of Hantz Farms, it's
a little bit more complicated
than that, because
Hantz lives in town.
He is a banker.
He's never grown
anything living.
Originally, his idea was to come
into my neighborhood, actually.
I live in Poletown, which
is near Eastern Market.
It borders Eastern Market.
And they wanted
to do vegetables.
That switched.
They're now doing a
hardwood tree farm.
And by all accounts, they've
cleaned up the neighborhood.
The neighbors over there
really seem to love it.
I've talked to some
of them myself,
and they're really
into it, which
is in terms of
development, what I go by.
Many other people think it's
a land grab, very simply,
a way they got the land
very inexpensively,
in a way that someone
that's small time, like me
or my neighbors,
don't have access to.
And so we'll see.
Time will tell.
They were going
to do vegetables,
and now they're
doing hardwood trees
to cut them down someday
and sell them for money.
And we'll see what happens.
There are a lot of promises
that we just won't know.
But looking at American
history, those promises
don't always seem to
bear out for those that
don't have much to begin with.
SPEAKER: Pivoting a
little bit from Detroit,
I want to talk about two things.
And I also wanted to open
it up to the audience
in a little bit.
But one of the things, I
think, on a lighter note,
because a lot of the places
in the beginning of the book,
and even through
the end, you talk
about just places that are
special to you in Detroit,
bars that you would write
in, and things like that.
So what are some of
the places that you've
become accustomed to or you're
a regular at in Detroit,
for folks that are interested
in visiting and getting to know
the city at a deeper level?
DREW PHILP: I'm
somewhat of a recluse.
So I only go to a
few places anymore.
SPEAKER: You don't have
to give away your secrets.
DREW PHILP: No, no no.
I'd be happy to.
So the place I generally write
at is called Trinosophes.
This is a coffee house
in Eastern Market.
It's owned by a man named Joel
Peterson and a woman named
Rebecca Mazzei, who have been
great patrons of the arts
in Detroit for a long time.
They're wonderful people.
It's very much a hub
of culture and writing,
and rather diverse,
which I look for.
As we talked about earlier, the
DIA is just an absolute gem.
It is just an absolutely
world-class museum.
They always have
events going on.
There's always something to do.
The main collection is great.
I just can't say enough
good things about the DIA
and the DFT, the
Detroit Film Theater.
And when I drink, which
is rarely any more,
I drink in Hamtramck.
Hamtramck is a
great place to go,
because it's only
two square miles.
You can walk to all of them.
And they all have a little
bit different flavor,
but they're all
pretty much dive bars.
They're all good.
So I do that.
I spend a lot of
time at home now.
SPEAKER: My other question,
before I kick it over
to the audience, is
around technology.
And you are, by no
means, a Luddite.
You have a website.
You are on social media.
You're on various platforms.
But the book talks a
lot about physical work,
being involved in
disconnecting a little bit.
So I'm wondering how
you balance those things
in your personal
life a little bit.
Because you're a writer,
you're connected a lot.
And how do you balance
working on a house
and doing that, or
living your life
in a certain way with the
values that you talked about
in the book?
DREW PHILP: So I don't have
the internet at my house.
I don't keep the
internet at my house.
It makes me read.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
DREW PHILP: Right.
I was never allowed to
watch TV when I was a kid.
I just got my first
TV a week ago.
I'm super stoked.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] is
catching up on "Game of Thrones"
right now.
DREW PHILP: I watched
the first season on DVD.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So for my own sanity,
I need to disconnect
a little bit, because I have
to use the internet for work,
and Twitter and Facebook, as not
only a promotional tool for me,
but also informational
gathering.
And just to have these
nightmares beamed
into your eyes by something you
keep in your pocket all day,
I need to be able
to disconnect from.
And I think there's
nothing like physical work.
There is no sense--
maybe, I don't know.
Maybe it would be
interesting to see.
I've never written a program
or coded anything where you
can turn it on and it works.
For me, there's nothing
like turning the key
in a car that doesn't work, and
then having that engine roar
to life.
It's very immediate.
It's very visceral.
And I haven't found any
way to replace that,
even in writing, even
having things published.
I'm on the staff at "The
Guardian" newspaper.
It doesn't compare
to turning that key
and having that
engine come to life.
I do think we're losing
a sense of wildness
that we talked about
a little bit, too.
I think the world is
becoming less wild.
And in some sense, that's good.
And others, we're, I think,
losing some of the values that
come with that.
One of them is self-sufficiency.
I'm very big on
self-sufficiency.
I want to try to be as
self-sufficient as possible,
which also has its downsides, as
well, especially when you talk
about community and what
that means, what it means
to be part of a community.
But like I said, there's
nothing like turning that key.
SPEAKER: I've got 1,000
questions that I could ask him.
But is there anybody
in the audience
that has questions about
Detroit, anything in the book?
AUDIENCE: I'm still struck by
when you walked into the house,
probably for the first time,
and saw what sounded like pretty
terrible conditions.
And you clearly,
from what you said,
have a lot of love
for those around you
and your neighbors in the city.
How do you manage that
juxtaposition of the conditions
you walked into in
the home and whatever
people had created
that with the way
you feel, generally, about
your surrounding neighbors?
DREW PHILP: An
interesting conversation
I often think about is
scrappers, like people
scrapping these places out.
So oftentimes, these houses will
get burned down for the copper,
or the copper wires
and the copper pipes
will be ripped out.
It's hard for me
to hate on that,
because like people
have no other option.
This is what folks
are doing to survive.
And nobody's making a profit.
Nobody's getting rich off that.
They're just trying to feed
their family or themselves
or whatever.
What troubles me is, I guess,
on the governmental level,
where people are overseeing
and looking at this,
we're demolishing incredible
amounts of houses.
I forget how many it is a day,
but it's like a dozen a day
or something, like 10,000
over the last year.
And to me, that seems like a
staggering waste of resources.
I think that we could
harvest many of the things
in these house, which would
be better for the environment.
We could use that to build the
new housing stock in the city
that we obviously need.
And we could provide
people lots of jobs.
What I'm fearing is
the loss of creativity
in how we do stuff like that.
So I could look at a house
that was filled the trash
and say, OK, we can do this.
It's not a big deal.
It also kept me out of trouble.
So I didn't waste my 20s in
a cloud of marijuana smoke
and cat videos.
I knew I would have something
that would always keep me busy.
When I didn't have a job or
if I couldn't have a job,
I would always have something
to do and something to work on.
So I think we could use a
little more imagination.
And I think imagination
is absolutely essential,
which is why when we see
art programs and music
programs being
removed from schools,
it's troubling, because
who's going to create
the next things of the future.
AUDIENCE: Do you feel
a sense of listlessness
from having finished the
house and the project is done.
Would you want to buy
another house and fix it up
for your cousin
is on your agenda?
DREW PHILP: I do, somewhat.
So the house is not
totally finished.
I'll probably be working on the
house for the rest of my life.
It's very nice now.
I live there.
And it's very comfortable.
And I have two bathrooms
and a guest bedroom
and stuff like that.
So that's nice.
And finishing a big
project like a book, I do.
I've spent 10 years in Detroit.
I was recently awarded a
Kresge Foundation grant.
So I have to be in the
city for a year for that.
And after that, I
may move to Europe,
to Scandinavia or
Northeastern Europe,
because I want to see the
opposite side of things, where
we have public transportation
and things work well
and socialism, just generally.
So I do.
I think I need some new
inspiration, just personally.
But Detroit will
always be my home.
I don't know how many
generations my family
goes back in Michigan.
We've been here for a long time.
My whole extended
family lives here.
So I'll never really leave.
But yeah, I don't think I want
to build another house right
now.
People ask me this, and I say,
if I could be 22 years old
again, for sure, I'd do it.
But I'm getting old.
It's hard on your body.
I'm looking at my father
and grandfather and uncles.
I'm the oldest male member of
my family, aside from an uncle,
with all of my fingers intact.
I haven't cut any of
my fingers off yet.
So there are real
consequences to these
and breathing all the stuff.
I did it once.
And I proved I can do it
to myself and my family.
And if the
opportunity comes up--
I'm attempting to buy the
house next door to me, still.
And if I'm able to
do that, the plan is,
I'll do with my father.
And in the lower
apartment, we'll
rent it out at market rate,
like hipsters or whatever,
and get as much money
for it as we can,
and which will support--
we'd like to house a refugee
family in the top, free
of cost, so they can get
on their feet, supported
by the market rate apartment.
SPEAKER: Can you
talk a little bit
about buying a house in Detroit?
So when the book
kicks off, you're
describing the process of
buying the house at the auction.
And in 2008, it was, you're
flipping through pages,
and you're trying to do that.
So that versus what
it is today and how
that's changed things
and changes the market
and changes the neighborhoods.
DREW PHILP: Sure.
Yeah.
So when I purchased my house,
it was at a live auction.
I had a bidder card that I
used to purchase this house.
It is done online
today, which has
an interesting
ethical segment to it.
So I think it's 40% of
Detroiters don't have access
to the internet, whether on a
computer or on their phones,
have absolutely no
access to the internet.
There is a serious issue with
internet literacy in Detroit,
as well, that people are
working on and trying to change.
But having the auction online
creates a huge power imbalance
between people who are savvy
with the internet and have
the time and resources to do
that and figure those things
out and those that don't.
So for example, the
neighbors behind me--
I only have two neighbors--
they're an elderly family.
The gentleman is
a little senile,
and he was taking
care of all the bills.
But the woman in the
house was running things.
And their house was
up for foreclosure.
And the auction was online.
These people are
80 years old, have
owned this house for 30
years, and owned it outright,
and are all of a sudden
facing getting thrown out
on the street.
Another neighbor of
mine and I ended up
purchasing the house for them,
with them paying us back.
There was somebody
bidding against us.
They would have thrown
my neighbors out.
So these things that are often
looked at as unalloyed goods
can have--
they're tools.
We tend to think of tools as
inert or just what they are,
but they can have these
unintended consequences
of this family not
being able to even begin
to understand how to
purchase this house back,
their own house.
Back on the internet,
when my neighbor and I
are bidding against--
I [INAUDIBLE] the guy.
He was buying dozens of
properties. that day.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And as a just side note, you
have to put a $2,000 deposit
down online to buy a house.
There's a barrier to
entry, even if you want
to buy a house in the city.
That
DREW PHILP: The amount
of structural poverty
is staggering.
Until you really see it, with
people living without water--
one in six homes has
been shut off to water.
One in four houses has
been foreclosed upon.
And when you see people living
without water and electricity
and in America, it's
not only heartbreaking,
but mind-blowing.
It's wild that we allow
these things that go on.
So even $2,000 is completely
unreachable for many people.
AUDIENCE: Looking at the
housing market now in Detroit,
I'm sure that it's
rising exponentially.
DREW PHILP: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Would you say
that it would be hard
for, say, a Googler like
us to get in and purchase?
And if so, what is that
rate comparing to, if you
have any background in that?
DREW PHILP: Oh, sure.
I mean, there are
incredible deals.
If you want to live in Detroit,
buy a house there right now.
You can probably buy it
with what's in your savings.
The $500 houses, there's
not a whole lot of them.
The housing market
is rising rapidly.
But if you want to
purchase a house
and become part
of the community,
absolutely, go for it.
Do it tomorrow,
because those prices
are going up consistently.
I do always tell people,
there's a huge difference
in buying a property to
make money for yourself,
becomes an absentee landlord.
The way I put it is that we want
things to flourish in Detroit,
but we want them to have roots.
So I get a lot of
people calling me,
hey, help me buy some
investment properties there.
It's like, no, man,
that's not what I'm about.
I want a good, strong community.
I want to know my neighbors.
I want to have people
over for dinner.
If you're trying to
do that, do it now.
Get in right now.
And people will accept you.
I mean, it's amazing that people
in Detroit just want equality.
They're not asking
for revenge, which
is, I think, a huge
credit to people.
And people like me,
who are young and white
and look different
than many people,
have largely been
accepted, to Detroit's
enormous, enormous credit.
So if you want to
do it, do it now.
SPEAKER: And there's a
couple of different tracks
in terms of buying a house.
So you bought it
from the auction,
which you can do online now.
There's the Detroit
Land Bank that
has houses that usually
start around $1,000
that they auction off.
But there's
requirements in place,
whereas if you buy
it a certain way,
you could spend a lot of time
fixing it up, as you did.
If you buy it through
the Land Bank,
you have to meet certain
criteria and threshold
you have your house up
to date by certain days,
or they can take it back.
And you have to be a Michigan
resident and things like that.
They're trying to get people
to fix houses up on a timeline,
instead of saying,
oh, we'll just
sit on these houses for
20 years sort of thing,
and not invest
any money in them.
DREW PHILP: And you can
get a really nice house
with $20,000--
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
DREW PHILP: --and have a place
to live and have a part in-- it
feels good living there
a lot of the time,
because you can have an actual
impact and an actual direction
on what people go.
And I'm a big proponent
of buying houses
because, like for myself,
it keeps people someplace.
I think what people are
scared of in Detroit,
including myself--
and this used to happen more
often than it does now--
is people would
come in, very smart,
educated people would come
in from the Ivy League
universities and spend
a year in a Detroit
and make decisions that
they weren't around to see
the consequences of.
So I think people in
Detroit and myself--
everybody makes mistakes and
we all have to get along.
But if you just make
decisions that affect my life
and then leave for New York
or San Francisco or whatever--
I understand
everybody's got to go,
but there was a deluge of it.
And it was also people that
had so much more societal power
than the average Detroiter.
I think what people
want, including myself,
is people to come and be
part of the community.
And we've never met, but we'll
be neighbors for a long time.
And you treat people
in a different way
when that happens, I think.
SPEAKER: I think there
is another question.
AUDIENCE: You can go.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So my question was, are
there any organizations
that you feel like,
within Detroit, provide
especially good
opportunities for people
from different backgrounds
to mingle and get
a better understanding of what
it's like for real people.
DREW PHILP: Sure.
I think that we could
use more of them.
One of my favorites is the
Allied Media Conference, which
is a little bit off the radar.
I think they're
absolutely brilliant there
and really know what
they're talking about.
But I think the large cultural
institutions in the city
do that--
places like the DIA, the
Detroit Film Theater,
the Detroit Historical Society,
of the Charles Wright Museum,
which is an African-American
history museum.
I think they do, really,
honestly, the best job of this.
I think people are really trying
to work on how to do this,
but we don't know anymore.
I feel like in Detroit
we're building from scratch.
I mean, I did not--
10 years ago, there
was no place I
could go in Detroit where there
would be only white people.
And that is completely
different now.
I think people care about it.
And I think people are
trying to figure it out,
but we're not quite there yet.
I think the motives and
the intentions are good,
but we really don't know.
That's an active question
we're trying to figure out.
And think the large cultural
institutions are really
doing that the best.
SPEAKER: And I would also
say neighborhood groups.
So if you are interested in a
particular area or neighborhood
in Detroit, figure out when
their community meetings
are and just go to one.
That's the best way to meet
people from the community
and see the diversity in people
from different walks of life
all in one place.
The neighborhood I live
in has one once a month.
And I meet new people
every single time I go.
And that's been, outside of the
cultural institutions, probably
the biggest place for me.
And that's the thing, a lot
of neighborhoods in Detroit
still don't have
something like that.
That's a disparity
between neighborhoods
is folks have
organized in some ways
and have a non-profit or
something that's an organizing
force, and then
some neighborhoods
don't have that yet.
And that is a whole imbalance
of the neighborhoods that
might get developed
versus not is, do you
have someone speaking for
your voice in the city?
DREW PHILP: People
are friendly, too.
People who are just
straight-up friendly there.
And just saying hello, this is
something that cultural icon
Marsha Music, talks about a lot.
With white folks coming in,
it's just like, just say hi.
Go say hi to people.
It's a simple thing,
but it doesn't always--
we've gotten away from that
in our society, I think.
AUDIENCE: So you said
that you wanted to add
your voice to the chorus.
So are there other authors
or artist or activist
that you would
recommend we check out
if we're interested in
learning more about Detroit?
DREW PHILP: Certainly.
One of my favorite
artists in there,
a sound artist or
musician, is named
Sterling Toles, Detroit
underground techno,
just came out with a
wonderful album called
"Resurgent Cineribus."
Sterling's a
generational Detroiter,
a fascinating, brilliant man.
Marsha Music is
another one who is also
a writer in the city that
is absolutely brilliant,
also a generational Detroiter.
Oh, who else?
So I think I
mentioned Trinosophes.
I would totally start there.
This is another one
of these places.
It's a coffee house
in Eastern Market
where a lot of
artists and writers
hang out that you can see.
So the Master
Musicians of Jajouka
is the oldest band in the world.
When they came to
the United States,
they played Bonnaroo
Music Festival,
they played the Kennedy Center,
and they played Trinosophes.
So that's another good one.
There's the "Belt Magazine"
is publishing "The Detroit
Neighborhood
Guidebook" on the 24th,
I think, is the release
party at Signal-Return,
also in Eastern Market.
Oh who else?
SPEAKER: And Aaron Foley
is the writer of that book.
So if you haven't
checked him out--
DREW PHILP: Aaron Foley.
SPEAKER: Yeah, because
he wrote a book called,
"How to Live in Detroit and
Not Be a Jackass," which
is definitely a good
read if you're thinking
about moving to Detroit.
DREW PHILP: Sure.
In terms of visual art, Tiff
Massey is a jewelry designer,
amongst other things.
She is just incredible.
I mean, there's a lot
of underground talent.
I tell people, if you want
to be an artist, if you're
an emerging artist, Detroit
is absolutely the best place
to live in in the United States
because it's inexpensive,
because you can have space and
materials that are available,
but also because there is
just an incredible artistic
community happening
there just bursting
with ideas and discussions.
And like I said, a coffee
house like Trinosophes,
you can walk in there, if
you've been in town long enough,
know every single
person in there,
and just have a discussion
with a map-maker who's
mapping the racial
politics in Detroit
next to somebody who's making
Afrocentric Afrofuturistic
jewelry next to somebody like
Adrienne Maree Brown, who
is writing Afrofuturism
stories in the vein of Octavia
Butler that are
becoming very popular.
AUDIENCE: It seems like an
inhibitor to moving to Detroit
and setting up
[INAUDIBLE] school system.
Also, when people have
families [INAUDIBLE] when
you send your kids to school.
Have you seen a
movement around helping
to improve the Detroit public
school system or any schools
within Detroit?
DREW PHILP: Sure.
The school system
is trash, obviously.
And I do see people,
younger folks with kids,
starting to stay.
That was always the big thing.
That was the tipping point
for where the city was--
if you had kids, did you stay?
People are starting
to figure it out,
and that's almost exclusively
in private and charter schools.
There are some public charters,
like the Grace Lee Boggs
School, which is
right next to me,
which I am a huge proponent of,
that does a really good job.
They do place-based education,
which they use the challenges
and resources in
the neighborhood
to teach their students about
being good community citizens.
So yeah, it's still a
question, but I definitely
see people beginning to
figure this question out.
Another one is the
Waldorf School.
Lots of my friends send their
children to the Waldorf School
there.
It is happening.
I don't think,
unfortunately, it's
happening-- just
the real politic,
not really happening in the
Detroit public schools yet.
And to be honest, I don't
really see a path out of it yet.
Do we have time for one more?
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the techno scene.
And I was just
curious what you feel
the impact, whether good or bad,
of something like [INAUDIBLE]..
DREW PHILP: Oh, yeah.
I mean, I think it's great.
People come from all
over the world to see--
in Germany and Belgium,
it's called Detroit music.
We invented it.
It's one of our cultural icons.
And I think, actually, we
could do a whole lot more
to support electronic
music in Detroit.
And it's a big, huge deal.
And it came from here.
I'm not a huge electronic
music fan myself,
but I have enormous
respect for someone
that can take the
noises of the factory
and create this beautiful
thing out of it.
That's so human to me, to take
this mechanical, inhuman thing
and make something
beautiful out of it.
I actually think, in Detroit,
we could do a whole lot more
to support that.
There's kids like Kyle Hall, who
is another Detroit artist you
might want to check out, that
will play to 20 people at Motor
City Wine bar, and
then will fly to Berlin
and play to 20,000
people, for real.
SPEAKER: I think the city's
getting a little bit better
in terms of recognizing things.
I mean, we're just getting
[INAUDIBLE] the Motown
Museum, which was
literally just a house,
and now they're building
an actual full-on museum
over there.
But yeah, there's
still a lot of work
to do in terms of recognizing
music history, cultural history
of the city.
DREW PHILP: And
we're starting to.
It's getting better.
And I hope electronic music,
techno, is really something.
I mean, Carl Craig and
Carl Cox are still around.
You can see them at the bar.
This is like legend--
it's like seeing Jimi
Hendrix at the bar.
So yeah, I hope--
I think we can do a better
job of it, actually.
And I would like to see
that celebrated even more.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Well, if there's no
more audience questions,
thank you, Drew, for coming.
DREW PHILP: Thank
you for having me.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]